[Musique]
m
nous
mais plus n'avait rien
[Musique]
gay pride
quel everson traduisons soyons fier d'en
être libérons nous soyons fier d'en être
homosexuel ces hommes ces femmes qui
manifestent devant des passants un peu
interloqué sur la protection de la
police avec un drapeau américain ce
problème eux-mêmes pédéraste et
lesbiennes leur mouvement à leur
mouvement de libération des homosexuels
en amérique
cette manifestation se déroule à new
york ville où l'on en a vu d'autres
ailleurs en amérique il faut bien le
dire elle ferait scandale dans la
plupart des villes américaines
les homosexuels sont l'objet de la
suspicion populaire ils sont écartés de
beaucoup d'emplois et ne peuvent en
principe prétendre à aucune carrière
politique
c'est justement ce contre quoi le
mouvement de libération des homosexuels
entend protester à leur manière les
homosexuels américains réclament ce que
réclame beaucoup de minorités
américaines être intégrée tout en
affichant sa différence à leur manière
aussi ils prétendent réunir dans leur
confrérie des gens de toutes classes de
toutes conditions et de toutes ans
inutile d'ajouter que la majorité
silencieuse qui soutient le président
nixon contemple à la télévision ce genre
de manifestation d'un oeil rond
[Musique]
je
le puritanisme américain avait longtemps
tenu sous le boisseau les tendances
homosexuelles la révolution des femmes
la libération explosif des moeurs a
conduit les homosexuels à sortir de
l'ombre et à revendiquer le droit
d'exister au grand jour sans brimades
sociale ou légal
[Musique]
et
je n'appelle bruce valeur je suis le
directeur du mouvement homosexuel
nationale new york
notre organisation représente les
homosexuels dans tout le pays une partie
de nos activités est relié au mouvement
féministe
l'autre concerne spécifiquement le
mouvement homosexuel
j'aimerais vous présenter d'abord
l'homme avec lequel je partage ma vie
bill blanc tu sais mon époux je ne sais
pas si vous avez un mot en français pour
désigner cela ici n'aimons pas beaucoup
les mots de marie ou de femmes qui ne
correspondent à rien je vous présente
aussi de nos amies lesbiennes marguerite
et caroline il faut ajouter encore que
si vous regardez bien mes amis ils ne
correspondent absolument pas l'image
stéréotypée construit d'un homosexuel
la plupart d'entre nous sont dans ce cas
en fait en bon nombre de gens qui sont
vos amis vos proches vos voisins de
palier est à d'hommes et de femmes que
vous croisez dans la vie vous ne savez
pas qu'ils sont homosexuels
et pourtant ils le sont je crois que
c'était important de le lire lorsque
j'étais dans la marine je ne me rendais
pas compte qu'ils avaient les
homosexuels je me savais simplement à
cause du rapport kinsey mais ça ne soyez
pas du tout en tant que lesbienne je
vois deux directions d'actions possibles
d'abord la lutte très âpre pour nos
droits dans laquelle nous sommes engagés
à new york
nous essayons d'obtenir d'habiter ou
nous voulons droit de garder notre
emploi le droit à toutes les
infrastructures publiques tout en étant
ouvertement homosexuel
pour ce qui concerne le mouvement des
lesbiennes nous essayons de nous définir
nous mêmes
jusqu'à maintenant ce qui se passait
c'est que les autres le définissait time
magazine et d'autres journaux musique
qui nous étions or ce qui nous intéresse
c'est que des lesbiennes parle
d'elle-même et 10 qui elles sont
vraiment encore dans ce pays des lois
très répressives au terme desquelles il
est interdit d'avoir des rapports
homosexuels même entre adultes
depuis longtemps la plupart des pays
européens ont aboli ces lois il vous en
campagne pour qu'on les abolisse ici
nous avons déjà réussi d'entrée et a
aujourd'hui certains tentent même
d'élever le problème homosexuel ou plan
politique et électoral comme le fait
avec milk
le mouvement homosexuel c'est un peu
comme le mouvement des femmes et il ya
quelques années ont commencé à en parler
mais les gens ne connaissaient pas grand
chose
dans certaines villes comme san
francisco on connaît le mouvement mais
ailleurs presque pas et si je suis élu
adjoint au maire ce sera à la une de
tous les journaux
mais déjà la prise de conscience
commence si vous êtes élu vous aurez le
pouvoir de changer la condition des
homosexuels
non je n'aurais pas le pouvoir mais ma
position me donnera une tribune et cela
peut aider à changer les choses
pour soir c'est une véritable marée
humaine qui déferle qui défilent en ce
moment même dans les rues de paris si le
gros de la troupe est arrivée sur la
pelouse de reuilly la marche gay
lesbienne n'est toujours pas terminée vu
le nombre de participants 270 mille
personnes selon les organisateurs venus
de l'europe entière le reportage de
caroline douillet et de xavier colombie
europe 1 ça veut dire de se montrer
s'assumer qui l'on aime et qui on est
les gays et lesbiennes étaient 300
milles cet après midi dans les rues
parcs et se sentait bien entendre
[Musique]
dans la foule européenne cette année
beaucoup envient les scandinaves
exemplaire car seul pays au monde à
avoir légalisé le mariage civil entre
homos et donner les mêmes droits sociaux
et juridiques
a tous je vis ouvertement de son
homosexualité au travail j'ai des amis
hétéros et homos une vie tout à fait
normale en somme c'est la vieille
tradition libérale des scandinaves en
faites vous lsi si l'on pense quoi
[Musique]
les français eux sont plutôt optimistes
le contrat d'union civile s'annonce bien
les politiques présents ont rappelé leur
détermination
j'ai une idée de ma détermination et de
celle de quelques responsables notamment
parmi les députés socialistes donc
déterminés nous ferons aboutir ce texte
le plus vite possible mais pour
l'instant il reste encore les points
noirs le désir d'enfant l'adoption
impossible les droits sociaux qui sont
l'héritage dans le foule toujours pas
reconnu
quand on change de boulot par exemple
quand on arrive dans une nouvelle
ambiance on a toujours obligée de se
justifier outre à des détours des
contours et s'il y en a un peu marre
dont les maisons de retraite ouverte à
tous quand on connaît la différence de
certains vieux on leur fait envie
triste on a vu à que l'homicide il reste
les filles qui n'osent pas facilement la
visibilité et tous ceux qui ne voient
encore les homos que comme des folles ou
des drive-in
mais les mentalités évoluent les hétéros
était là aussi qu'en soutien pour avoir
conscience que demain nos enfants
peuvent être homosexuel donc faut déjà
accepté au départ
l'espoir d'être un jour tout à fait
comme tout le monde est en marche
ce soir et toute la nuit ce sera la fête
sur la pelouse de reuilly la
traditionnelle gay pride joue les
records et des sans doute par le soleil
près d'un demi million de personnes dans
les rues de paris pour ce défilé marqué
cette année par la volonté de combattre
toutes les discriminations et pour la
première fois les politiques avaient
envie de s'afficher les grands partis de
gauche à l'écouté de la communauté
homosexuelle avec en tête
bertrand delanoë habitués c'est vrai de
cette manifestation
mais j'avais encore un maire de paris
n'avait conduit de bout en bout ce
mouvement dorothée cochard marie pierre
cassignard et leur ans iront tout un
temps la discrétion est de rigueur et
les homosexuels étaient à peine tolérés
manifestation syndicale trente ans plus
tard ils sont cinq cent mille à définir
à la gay pride et ce sont les hommes
politiques qui court après sa façon de
parler
ils se sont placés en tête du cortège
avec dans le rôle du maire légitime
d'arnaud la nuit moi j'étais là les
années précédentes à la gay pride
ils m'ont élu ce qui veut dire que les
parise et les parisiens sont des gens
qui aiment la liberté et qui savait lire
leurs nerfs sur son projet
quelle que soit son identité dans
nouveau du plus ancien
le candidat vert à la présidentielle
c'était la première gay pride
on était très isolée à l'époque je me
réjouis maintenant que tout le monde
vienne
je crois que quand on demande rurale en
tout le monde se précipitera pour avec
de prague avoir vent régnié et dans le
rôle du pénitent l'un des rares
représentants eu des erreurs comme celle
appréhendés le bal ce qu'on peut
rencontrer récupération ou pas les
homosexuels font plutôt satisfait il y
avait un pouvoir un pouvoir électoral
chez les homos
aux hétéros le patch n'est qu'un début
distille il faut encore progresser
notamment sur les droits parentaux
je pense que c'est vachement important
je pense que les personnes homosexuelles
sont capables de donner de l'amour aux
enfants au même site que les hétéros
c'est clair avoir des enfants pouvoir
adopter pouvoir se marier avoir les
mêmes droits que les hétérosexuels
prêtre supprimer toutes les
discriminations
tel était le mot d'ordre pour que la
société évolue
la qualité de ce samedi en france avec
d'abord la marche des fiertés la
traditionnelle gay pride qui cette année
après un temps d'avancé sur 2007 la
campagne présidentielle est déjà ouverte
sur un thème de société qui pourrait
faire la différence
le mariage et l'adoption pour les
couples du même sexe
en tête de cortège françois hollande et
de nombreuses personnalités du ps
anne-sophie soumis le comte jean marc
technique un défilé haut en couleur
politique
au coude à coude avec les habitués de la
gay pride
françois hollande tente de se faire une
place en 1996 il était venu défendre le
pacs je viens de 10 ans apprennent à la
veille d'une échéance importante pour
dire que sur la question du mariage de
l'ouvrir aux homosexuels l'égalité pour
tous si la gauche a tranché est sortie
c'était des affiches à l'ump on préfère
envoyer les jeunes en éclaireur pour la
première fois le parti a même financé un
char
du mpda partie de liberté certains
s'expriment contre et ils ont le droit
de le faire contre le mariage des gays
d'autres textes en cours nous sommes là
et ils vous disent ophrenie loin des
discours politiques
valérie et wanda sont là pour témoigner
elles sont maman de deux enfants et
milite pour être enfin comme elles
disent des citoyennes à part entière
[Musique]
on ne savait pas se marier s'intégreront
qu'on vit ensemble
donc voilà on espère que les politiques
vont un petit peu se réveiller parce que
la société elle nous accepte plutôt bien
mais les politiques sont très en retard
six cent mille personnes dans la rue
deux fois plus que l'an dernier
le débat sur le mariage gay et
l'homoparentalité sera difficile à
occulter d'ici l'élection présidentielle
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé aujourd'hui à paris
à l'occasion de la gay pride musique et
fait bien sûr mais aussi revendications
quarante ans après le combat
homosexuelle pour l'égalité continue
aurélia bros et patrick rissmiller il
n'en revient pas mais c'est bien elle
l'a examiné lee la star américaine a
demandé elle-même à être présente pour
l'ouverture de cette marche
quarante ans après le début de la lutte
des homosexuels dans la foule des
centaines de milliers de personnes gays
lesbiennes bisexuels transsexuels et
était en au mélange des genres
pour mémoire de fourmies
le but c'est de montrer qu'on peut
manifester de façon soyeuse avance lâche
on rigole au mieux vos droits
c'est tout c'est la journée à la croate
on l'a été reprise pour que les hétéros
puissent s'intégrer parmi lesquels la
fête ne fait pas oublier les raisons de
cette marche héros gay men sudo
afghanistan comme le rappelle ce char
dans plusieurs pays
les homosexuels sont parfois condamnés à
mort en france la situation est bien
différente
mais aujourd'hui le mot d'ordre c'est
l'égalité des citoyens de seconde zone
moi je suis avec mon ami depuis
maintenant 17 ans binger pas me marier
avec lui alors que je l'aimais qu'il
m'aime
j'ai envie d'avoir dans le port mais si
j'avais envie d'un mois eh ben je peux
pas l'adopter
cet après midi beaucoup de parents homos
sont d'ailleurs venus avec leurs enfants
nous on a une grande joie d'avoir des
enfants et si les revendications sont
sérieuses une fois encore cette année
l'humour était un invité d'honneur
[Musique]
on reste fortement marqué par les
premières images que l'on découvre
enfants à la télévision
[Musique]
cette pensée m'amuse car l'un de mes
premiers souvenirs aurait pu être celui
des émeutes de stonewall le 28 juin 1969
à new york
[Applaudissements]
ulcéré par les rafles et la répression
policière 2000 travaux et jeunes gays
s'oppose aux autorités
ce coming out tonitruant marque le début
officiel des luttes pour les droits des
gays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis 1970 les gay pride du monde
entier commémore chaque année les
émeutes de stonewall
véritable fête de la tolérance ludique
et engager les gay pride eux sont
devenus au fil des années le symbole
médiatique de la visibilité et de la
reconnaissance des gais
[Musique]
ld moigne du formidable changement des
mentalités qui s'est opérée vis-à-vis
des gays en l'espace d'une quarantaine
d'années la télévision à d'ailleurs
contribué à changer du tout au tout
l'image des homosexuels auprès des
hétéros sujet tabou hier caricaturer et
mais brisée à l'extrême les gays sont
devenus un modèle à suivre
regarde moi c'est cette révolution du
regard ultra rapide et ultra radical que
retrace ce film comme un retour sur soi
est un symbole des avancées
démocratiques
[Musique]
les violences contre la gay pride de
moscou en 2007
les attaques homophobes en lettonie
hongrie en pologne nous rappelle que les
droits des gays reste fragile dans près
de 75% des pays dans le monde
[Musique]
cette remise en cause de la liberté
sexuelle annonce rethel une forme de
régression
[Applaudissements]
ces violences homophobes mais vox en
effet les états unis des années 1960
quand brimer culpabiliser on te les
homos été raflé par la police auxiliaire
de l'ordre moral en place la télévision
officielle présentée un leurre les gays
toujours de manière négative et
contribue à les rendre d'autant plus
coupable aux yeux de la société et de
l'opinion publique
c'est une culture de la peur une culture
je rase les murs une culture je me marie
et gilles double vie en hôtel ou malade
mental ou pêcheurs ou kamenar c'était le
saut trois possibilités
présenté comme un danger pour la société
les homosexuels témoigne caché aux
débuts de la télévision
sauf quand celle ci décide de s'en
moquer dans mon enfance les gays étaient
surtout présents dans les émissions de
variétés l'équivoque le double sens le
non-dit régnait en maître
on s'y affichait de ninon sans jamais se
firent mais en revanche quand la télé
décidé de montrer les homos à l'écran
c'était toujours en affichant la
caricature de la fon maniéré efféminé
précieuse jusqu'à en devenir ridicule
mais pour un jeune gay de l'époque
conditionnée par la télé cette
représentation avait vraiment quelque
chose d'effrayant à laquelle je
redoutais de m'identifier
[Musique]
mon dieu quelle merde mais bon ces
images ont été implantés dans l'esprit
les américains pour qui être gay rimait
avec affecté faible et frivole mais je
ne suis pas d'accord tu réalises que tu
me demandes du projet tu n'as exil comme
un lépreux avait à l'époque ce sont
généralement des hétéros qui joue les
homos comme dans la cage aux folles avec
michel serrault et jean poiret en rôle
titre
créée en 1972 au théâtre puis porté à
l'écran ce succès mondial nommé deux
fois aux oscars est toujours représenté
à londres et à paris a suscité pas mal
de polémiques sur la vision qu'il
donnait de l'homosexualité
[Musique]